you're gonna kill it on this one I can feel it
this is gonna be the best one yes citizens of the
reject Nation how's it going people it's time for
another feature film reaction an animated feature
today we're gonna check out Puss and Boots The
Last Wish and in the co-host see surprise surprise
it's Roxy stryer a big surprise big surprise he's
supposed to be here today and there and and yet
here we both are wait why weren't you supposed
to be here I wasn't supposed to be here how did
either of us get here today either way we're here
now I've only seen the Shrek movies so I am going
in very cold you are an expert no yeah no I have
loved Puss in Boots since last night at one in the
morning killing it yeah big expert I did just
watch the first one it was really cute okay it
was they did a good job with it I'm curious what
the Last Wish means like what you know usually I
feel like that's not associated with cats that's
gonna be ambiguous they're not gonna explain it oh
you're on social media right oh yeah Roxy stryer
keeping it simple for the kids and the World Girls
yeah go give the World Girls some love subscribe
hit notification bells for them for us for this
channel leave a like on this video and hey guys
if you want to see the full experience with all
the stuff that doesn't make it to the reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com real
reject sync up with your own copy of Puss in Boots
Last Wish join us for the adventure Roxy is there
any anything else you want to tell the people
before we get to business you really emphasize
whoa that's new for you I've not seen this
DreamWorks bumper to put the bad guys in there
and Dragons
skadoosh that's what Kung Fu Panda
says boss baby trolls what's up Erica
my friend works on trolls oh hi Erica
would you rather be the moon or the boy
um I want to be the boy chilling with the moon
cool you know I gotta think for moose a little
lunar kind of guy you know I'm a solo girl that's
good balance each other out you're a world right
first star I see tonight I wish I may I wish I
might have this wish I wish tonight The Last Wish
the titular wish that was also the best ASMR I've
had in a while yeah Wishing Star fell from the sky
into Super Mario World I'm the legend of a single
wish locked away in the star waiting rounded
oh man it's gonna be like the end of Thor
love and thunder everyone's favorite Thor
movie why you think there's a kid yeah he's
gonna wish for his dead kid to come back
very kid-friendly hey hola amigo good to see
you again oh he has his boots back hey don't
you lose him kind of this girl like took
him for a sec girl cat she was just puss
in bare feet if it was kind of a sexy move
of hers she was like I've got your boots
[Applause]
yeah sure you can
I should know this but who's voicing puss it's
Santonio Banderas Tony Flags man you think he's
singing yes I'm gonna say yes for now I think he's
got the pipes that is based on nothing other than
he's a Dreamboat Bishop's knife trick man all day
my clothes my wig hmm my portrait [Music] arrest
these filthy patterns and bring me the head apples
and Boots hey this is a buddy where's the music
clink clink on beat I wish
this is my theme song [Music]
and his pants come off yes you wanted
that too much classic comedy people's
pants falling down and he did a p like Zorro
perfect but are his pants coming off or not
puss in Kaiju duck tires don't work on cat
oh he's a martini guy I can see it you think
it's Jenner vodka definitely gin milk and gin oh
yeah that's the kind of white russian I won well
you know that's just like uh your opinion
man and the rest of you play double time
it's getting a little bossy for me really
yeah I don't love how bossy he is now
like a little too big for his britches
you know maybe that's part of his Arc
wow ah it's like a torture method
I like the blend of Animation Styles
they've got going on the subtle mix
I don't know it's making me kind of dizzy
also that I can see that especially if
you saw this like big and in 3D that's
what the kids like they like a roller
coaster kids love vomiting [Laughter]
how do you go you think you got his eye patch
somebody plundered his eye and sold it for
riches whoa you want to see something cool
get your bell rung [Music] [Applause]
my man
I'm like so happy we're done with
that moment really too much it was
a lot of sensory overload don't
worry we're just getting started
one more number I call this one
the legend will never die oh
damn taken out by a bell too you kind of
predicted that get your bell wrong where am
I not to worry you're in good hands my hands
all states hands liters to draw out the evil
humors wow suit yourself more for me you put a
leech down shirt yeah who knows where it landed
died I have nine lives and how many times
have you died already I haven't counted I
am not really a math guy you know gato
ugh do you think it's gonna be eight
he's died eight times he's already died
nine times he's a zombie now no it's gonna
be eight right It's gotta be eight It's gotta
be one yeah yes it's not your night phyllises
I have uh dogs playing poker picture
okay this is a cute Montage I mean oh
this will revolutionize trouble watch [Laughter]
does this have shellfish in it oh God
he's allergic the oven too high oh [Music]
that makes eight push I knew it you are
down to your last life I'm very smart
dude you should write movies is there any
safe place you can go any special someone
you can rely on in this moment of me yeah
the girl this is the address of Mama Luna
she is a cat fancier oh he's on the lookout for
a new lap cat oh no death comes for us all treat
[Music]
takes the whole ball rude don't worry he's gonna
like sprinkle him out to all the other cats of the
land I also like the Wicked Witch of the West back
there me that was you that doctor is crazy man you
shouldn't stick to cutting hair all right what's
your prediction on what the Last Wish is he's
gonna have to give it up for something he wants
to wish for all the lives but he can't do that
gonna wish for someone to love whoa
can I get your autograph been following you for a
long time damn cold all right whose voice is this
I know I'm trying to piece together like it's
definitely Ethan Hawke doing a Spanish accent
he doesn't have a Spanish accent
a little bit all right let's get
it over there oh you know who it is Poker
Face Miss Congeniality it sounds like him
Benjamin brat oh maybe
yeah
you're not living out to the legend
oh his eyes yeah that's like perspective bump yeah
whoa
whoa no one mortality ah 80 cents I just love
the smell of fear hey Palm in the morning yeah
he's experiencing fear for the first time
oh no
what's the matter the for your
eye yeah get up pick it up
oh buddy is he a wolf yeah in sheep's
clothing oh now there now there bet who
will be at some point or maybe that's
just a wool coat dude he lost his sword
that would mess the tides up I
love a big beautiful moon like
that but that that's is that how that
tides work we'll watch Cosmos later on
you know what's really weird that they
call him Puss in Boots you're saying it
like it's his best friend Puss and Boots the
boots yeah no the boots are just as sentient
I am no longer worthy oh he's burying
the boots now he's just and there was
no boots he's just puss on grass two more a
hero to all a legend words were not enough
no you're doing great it's always great to
give your own eulogy it's a good exercise what
did you think I'd be too stupid to know what
your googly was who is your favorite Fearless
[Music] laughs
it's almost weird to see
him on all fours like yeah
meow
you're not from the health department are
you no you're not oh she is so cute she's
like Miss Swizzle yeah hop on the Magic School Bus
I bet you never even had a name I shall call you
Nichols bathing with your dirty cat is disgusting
yeah I I would take a separate
shower after that this is the
SE they must not oh
wow this is a person party pickle that's your
party so this is where dignity goes today
um truly bomber pickles I have so many questions
about that bathroom scene just now because I
never thought I would have to think about because
where is his when he's and then you sure nine so
I hear you I just don't get why none of them can
speak because they're domesticated I guess so
they don't have the magic oh no my dude that's a
Rip Van Winkle beard really let himself go these
are too small but these ones these ones are just
right oh my God yes that's fun track that cat see
that's who you should be totally just get yourself
three big old Burly dudes to follow you around
do you mind I'm trying to eat here I mean now
whatever what's wrong with that sorry it's a dog
you're a talking cat you're a talking cat let's
talk talking cat like the film a talking cat it
definitely is a dog right it's funny despite
all this best friend bonding you're still a
mystery to me pickles what's your story my story
do you feel like they're socks or mittens they're
mins I'm gonna go I'm gonna go definitive Mitten
what's happening I need the practice I'm gonna
be a therapy dog someday when people feel bad
they can rub my belly it'll make him feel better
this is so good I don't want to touch your belly
okay so what do you want I won't to be left alone
this is a lovely home I was just thinking
I would literally do anything to live there
you're back oh I never left
who are you more similar to
uh definitely the dog that would definitely
be more of the dog I never left he found me
I just got a Jackie outfit on
for the legendary pushing boots have
you perhaps seen him too soft is that
Windstone Jason Statham we'll see we'll
take bets I don't think we've got anything
right so far nope sniff him out you don't
tell me what to do do what she says fine
but all I can smell is cat pee oh yeah it
probably smells disgusting in there oh sure
probably be a slightly lightheaded leaving
a place like this oh here we go [Music]
no way that skirt is staying up like that it's uh
it's a modesty skirt it's rigid it's good everyone
loves for this one is a ginger you think this
scruffy geriatric bag of bones looks like a legend
dead and buried dead well that's that then what
say we going hibernate we have one chance to steal
it without it we'll never find the wishing stuff
that star has one wish to Grant One Wish think of
what that could mean for us you think his one
wish is for more lives but then he has to use
it on something else that's what I'm going
with yeah but if this person boots is such
a big deal maybe we shouldn't be desecrating his
grave no I don't think he will mine was he is me
too I'm so addicted the movie and
this haul has my initials on it
endlessly impressed I am why what does
it stand for in this stands for John Hall
yes duh get in and get out easy busy let me
squeezy I brought you a sword not a sword
it's a stick it's a stick sword go home
I love him again not friends rap for luck
let's start using that he's on his eyes he
is finally to see ourselves that is that's
definitely a Greg is definitely Puss in Boots
Greg and Boots representation matters yeah [Music]
oh I hated that oh I hate this delicious
oh JH Jack Horner Jack Hall yeah you couldn't let
me have that no is it the map to the Wishing Star
we must get this to the trophy oh my God I hate
this guy that's John Mulaney I'm pretty sure he
gives me the heebie-jeebies bro yeah that
character design is disturbing it's truly
disturbing after so many years of searching this
is my moment with the thumb forever stained the
master of all magic hey little Jack could you do
the thumb thing like in the fairy tale wasn't a
fairy tale it was only a nursery rhyme oh oh is
this real yeah pulled out a plum and said what a
good boy am I jack horn is real I think it's a
real like nursery rhyme I've never heard that
oh my God because you've
probably heard Pinocchio way more
lover cat yeah I've heard so much about this lover
cat she had no claws [Music] Katie pools kitty
kitty Soft Paws okay maybe she got
her own boots that's what happened
you promised us our weight in gold ever
hear of the Midas touch oh cool dibs
our weight in gold I hate it it's disgusting
well I love it it's distinguished Salma Hayek
or Penelope it's not a good look that we can't
tell the difference you should know you're the
Puss in Boots movies expert you watch this less
than 24 hours ago good girl you robbed me you set
me up you said you were going on some spiritual
Retreat Namaste and you're supposed to be dead
I got better crank I can't tell she We Like Her
I'm enjoying her no I mean like is she bad guy or
good guy Goldie yeah [Music] mediocre you know
chaotic neutral maybe the best Thief has won
[Music]
her mask is sick yeah I want one oh I don't know
why we do all the slow motion with the animation
you know to make it feel more real oh is that
a snake what are you gonna do with it [Music]
pies puss in pies
this idiot
oh no don't die hey look I found a sandwich in
here I think it's tuna I don't think that it's
tuna actually also he's allergic to maybe
just shellfish at least yeah who is this
guy I'm pussy's best friend no he isn't it
and his therapy dog definitely not trust me
trust you like I did in Santa Coloma really
Santa Coloma oh is that for the first movie
I don't remember if that's the name of where
it was but I realized that she didn't take his
boots she just got her own so he always had
his boots [Music] oh that'll do it accept s
my man oh he's getting cocky again
cool it's Goldilocks and the Bears is the
wolf the villain in that no I used to get
a Little Red Riding they were right here yeah
now porridge is the real villain too hot too
cold yeah the commodification of porridge
forcing this poor girl to either we're gonna
see Little Red Riding Hood then hey Alice in
Wonderland it's an Easter regulatorium in here
hey [Music]
get you my kitties and your little dog
and it was a pumpkin Carriage we got some
Cinderella going on yeah the Dark Forest
far within its bounds you'll find the Stars
plastic is it bad that I want them to kiss not
at all cat kiss I got a kiss cut the tension
what's your name oh I've been called all kinds of
things dog bad dog stupid dog big rats small Pig
rat face butt nugget for brains you know whoa
they're going for it that was interesting edgy
but I liked butt nugget butt nugget yeah yeah yeah
I've used button nugget before no one's that dumb
no one's that nice I don't trust you me neither
do I trust him more than I trust you no [Music]
yeah the chase is on I really can't stand him
this is who I want to be someday Jack Horner yeah
this does the initial thing you want to be
bulbous I want my legs to be incapable of
supporting my frame but still doing it somehow
I got the sandwich this must be the Dark Forest
freaky cool design yeah I
love it it's that icicles
it's back ready one two after you wait
what so mean foreign I can't stand you
sometimes bro like you wouldn't do the
same I would never all right [Music]
whoa really I'm like softballs yeah you are may
I please see them up no seriously you won't let
me hold it for even one minute nope you've got
to trust me oh what's going on with his eyes oh
figure oh oh really you call that
cute oh no oh look at her oh the
lashes wait a second so oh my
God what the pause the office
kiss kiss kiss kiss follow these Enchanted
chart it knows your path and knows your heart
they all have good hearts
[Music] [Applause]
wow oh
okay bummer odor over Undertaker reach through
the cave of lost souls really let me take a look
[Music] oh everyone's path is different but
I don't want them to separate me neither
sometimes in life you don't always get what you
want but if you try sometimes Rose mountains of
Misery the abyss of Eternal loneliness no
sheeps not loneliness I don't even have a
wish but can I try it it's gonna be the
easiest bath yeah the Rainbow Bridge we
get through the pocket full of posies what then
drift down the river of relaxation that sounds
fun no fair why does he get the good ones
wonder the feels of quick and easy solutions
this is your quest I don't want to impose you
hold them up really well don't you cross me
or your name will be ferromuerto okey dokey
that's a bar dead dog that's less of a bar
what's your one wish um
give me a minute it's one wish for for the
rest of your time you gotta make a good wish
can't tell you birthday wish rules or whatever
I've had your wishes something stupid [Music]
this must be the pocket full of posies
ashes ashes We All Fall Down it's running
time [Music] are these actually called Posies
they're hydroposes oh thank you that's a good
question though I don't know if I've actually
ever seen a real Posey I think all you have to do
is stop and smell the roses all I smell is bullsh
a lot of this is an edgy family film well it
is Puss in Boots it's true that is it is true
yeah me and my litter mates live with the
family a family full of pranksters who like
to play hide and seek and I was always it they
tried putting me in a packing crate a dumpster
and they put me in a sock with a rock in it
and then throw me in a river I nod a hole in
the sock and I swapped to the surface
damn gave you the mafia treatment you
of all people should have a wish I already
have a comfy sweater and two best friends
I got everything I could wish for he's so cute
he's gonna teach them both a little something
oh lovely this is so cute oh I'm so in right
now stop and enjoy life for a minute did you
come up with your wish I can't tell you it's
not gonna come true I'll come up with I'll
come up with one my wish is to know what my
wish would be my wish is to be more decisive
dang this looks sick this is
trippy start chopping on it
stop and smell the roses the heck out of this bike
whoa whoa oh my God that was sick
hey there all right magical Locust defoliate
no it's so mean no Jurassic world to me what
are you there a deadly fairy Put a Spell on the
forest then I I judge I sit on your shoulders
Jimmy Stewart but also yes I keep my secrets
and I play my cards close that's how you get a
Winnie hat never trust anyone they took her his
sweater it's like a sock sweater you were right
the beer is disgusting oh I won't make your
bag wow there's that handsome face I remember
the face I haven't seen since I Santa Coloma
no so that must be oh that's his hometown I
think that she met him in this is a path to get
my wish you mean my wish you mean My Wish sorry
make with the map or we'll see what
the unicorn horn really does you're
not gonna shoot a puppy are you a
jack yeah in the face why oh my gosh
a lot of this looks like a video game it's
got a little bit of video game a little bit of
that spider versus jitteriness yeah a little
bit of stuff that kind of looks hand-drawn
the wolf yeah oh
no go get the map thanks for the maps of pose
nostalgic Pines it's like
pining for Nostalgia clever
[Music] oh
what's wrong
been there honey oh oh my
God he's a therapy dog he is
oh that's really sweet thank you
thank you burrito perrito you left her at
the altar he was wrong I know I am ashamed
to her so badly yeah oh there's the wish
don't hurt the people you love kitty I
love the map we'll get it back we've been in
worse pickles who told you the name foreign
this isn't real none of this is
is great [Music] too soft [Music] just right
[Music]
do you know that was gonna happen I'm
a Futures here the day A Little Orphan
girl broke into our cabin and stole our hearts oh
came just right see I want her to win too yeah
I told you I liked her I think Mama bears Olivia
Coleman oh you okay see I am good so good soft
pass Saves the Day the first time I ever felt
the fear I ran it was a mistake it's okay no it's
not okay don't tell him it's okay it's not okay
wait what well I knew I could never compete
with you one true love yourself John
shut the front door yeah I didn't see that coming
I think she did show up I think you might be right
I think that's a good call she's let him off
the hook but she showed up she's giving him a
chance yeah rebuild you know I never had much
as a kid just loving parents stability in a
mansion and a thriving baked goods Enterprise
for me to inherit useless crap sounds good
[Applause]
can't bake a pie without losing a
dozen men oh your wish is horrible
you're horrible yeah yep what took you
so long idiot oh his wings chatty are you
okay you take the window I'll take the
chimney what do I take it looks like a
Thomas Kinkade painting uh the guard
area yeah yeah on your six got your
rears eyeballed and covered hands and
crew staring at your butts dogs are
good at that if you play your cards
right maybe we could share the wish
oh yeah stuck in the honey
nowhere to go softballs let's
see what the map has to say
this is a cool premise with like it keeps changing
depending on who's holding
it yeah getting good there
we're coming down
[Music]
I like that both of their boots
have heels yeah major eels hey
[Music]
oh this is so beautiful
I'll find a way out of here yeah listen
to him trust you go get burrito pussy's
gonna be fine because it's always been fine
especially now that he has no more lives to
burn he's gonna be a proper party
now about all nine of us are here
one who is your favorite Fearless hero I do
remember this one yeah it's a banger speaking from
one orphan to Another goldie you won the orphan
lottery I like his jib as well let's keep him what
he crimed
[Music] shut the piece who plays the shark
in Finding Nemo oh that sounds like goodness
don't do it don't go back to your old ways
puss were you really happy back then no
Nostalgia is the number one cause of
depression well he doesn't even have a soul
Savage Man Savage burn without us
[Music]
it's intoxicated is he real right now okay I was
there to witness all of them [Music] boots laughs
in the face of death oh is he actually deaf yeah
seems like that oh undeath straight up and I've
come for years straight up whose voice is this I
can see their face too like it's driving me nuts
go ahead run firing makes it more fun for me come
on soft pause you gotta rescue my man's heart
do not leave her no no no no no no no no no
[Music] horse All Is Lost what is this the star
the star you think it's a solid liquid
or gas it is crystalline solid solid
transition what's your just right what's
out blasted important I'm getting a
family that's what a problem probably
then everything will be will be just right
if this is something that will make
you happy we'll get you that wish
oh but I was in on Goldie and now a hater no
it's just me dies terribly by the way the oh
now that you care about my wish because you
haven't asked me but the only wish to wish
for is to wish for more wishes sorry I can't
help but I'm stealing your wish I am on my last
life I need to get my lives back without them
I am not what the legend get your lives back
just keep them out of mind the dog
perito should obviously get the wish yeah
you know how I'm feeling dizzy yeah
you know like those locked off POV
panning shots I need your
help duly noted but a little
bit whoa A lot of people get exploded
in this movie yeah out of death
[Music]
Goldie don't be a big brat
like I told you baby you're
the smash I'm the crap yes
I mean literally anybody but you
no this is good this is gonna be
good I'm glad for him he deserves it
maybe it's time to bury the hatchet I
I've only ever had one life sharing
it with you and Kitty has made it
pretty special one life is enough is enough
who's that he's here for me
[Music]
who's getting the Last Wish I
need your prediction yeah [Music]
it's interesting they can all see death
yeah maybe it's the magic of the star
ah the little dagger say hello
to my cartito blade thank you
[Music]
Ito makes everything so cute I know
oh dang dude beast mode pick it up pick it up pick
it up menacing he goes away right he's gonna leave
look death in the face and just and make the big
old cute eyes I come here for an arrogant little
Legend who thought he was Immortal but I don't see
him anymore oh with his eight other lives the wish
is yours you deserve someone you can trust come
on no no give it to the dog coming out of the bag
magic sneeze oh no no
no thank you [Music] The Last Wish
Starlight Star Bright first star I see
tonight I wish I may burrito I wish
I might please don't make that wish
oh seriously are you having a hernia
or something do it do it buddy
there's such pools of vulnerability
don't you know I'm dead inside by
the way your nose is bleeding I
was just buying some time for a team
friendship uh let's go get him Goldie
oh torture hey
no wish no one gets a wish
what did I do to deserve this everything every
[Laughter]
Terminator I wish somebody made a wish this
is dope I wish somebody may wish that's your
wish it's full circle one knife spend with you
is all that I could wish for please make out
cats cat cat love let's do it even it's so lame
they're just gonna hold the hands romance isn't
appropriate for children all right between
habits of violence and that's it sorry you
didn't get your wish gold enough but I did Mama
everything is just right oh no you've made me cry
I love love this little b
story yeah you know if it's
if it's about just they kind of like
it since that's what my friends call me
you know to be honest jumper is
pretty good yeah but no Workshop in it
yeah yes there literally was no Last Wish
[Music]
team friendship
team friendship we did not
agree to this yeah it makes
us look ridiculous too late now it's
official oh Steady As She Goes burrito
I thought that was gonna be the kiss
and to see some old friends oh Shrek
you think don't care you think they're Fiona
I don't think no no no no like some of the
side characters Maybe we're gonna go see the
gingerbread man again he turned into a gold egg
see see so solid but didn't you think like there
could be one wish I think that's part of the
message is that you know in this life you're not
gonna get a magic wish and thus it behooves you
to look around past the hardships and the trials
to the things that are already here to bless your
experience sounds like somebody who's definitely
not getting a magic wish hey you know okay Antonio
vendors Salma Hayek okay Harvey yet is he on what
we do in the shadows oh I should have called him
out Florence peace there you go got it got it Ray
Winstone that was a good one really good job okay
good good different guy I have no idea who that is
for a second yeah for a second I thought baby was
Wagner Mora he was in did you see
Elysium he's on like narcos yeah okay
probably why the voices sounded so good is they
got some really good voice people yeah yeah no
for sure and it's hard because you know it's I
feel like with every animated movie people get
have different levels of supporter frustration
for having like you know major actors do the
voice yeah where was Chris Pratt in this where
was Chris Pratt it's not complete without Chris
Pratt we have one wish is to have Chris Pratt
voiced at least half of these guys yeah is to
have Chris Pratt not voice anybody you don't want
to hear Rocket Raccoon Mario I do how'd you know
I'm excited yeah me too actually I'm excited
stop specifically despite despite Chris Brown
but uh but yeah Florence Pew yeah one and
two because like you're so I am so used to
seeing Florence do an American accent that I
always forget she's British so this is like
the first time I think I've probably heard her
actual voice throughout a movie see that's the
closest to a kiss we're gonna get oh I can't
believe they didn't make out yeah I wanted to
see some like Kitty tongue on tongue like yeah
with those like really extreme angles and stuff
oh yeah and the close-up on the cute eyes
and see like the little like you know the
little claw things on their tongues like you
know connecting and and velcroing together
claw thanks yeah cats have like coarse
tongues is there gonna be a third one
I don't know I mean it certainly feels like it
watching this at least I come uh yeah I mean oh
oh see this is this is one of the few
kinds of movies where it's like if they
had a sing-along or some kind of thing where
you could dance in the theater let's do it
maybe there'll be more songs in the next
one though I kind of feel like the whole
thing should be a Musical full-on musical I
would be down for that I would be down [Music]
I can't believe how many lines
I predicted in this movie dude
I am a child so hence exactly
you speak the language sick Bro
I would watch your animated children's
movie family I should say this is a
family and this this movie seemed like
it it wanted to push every boundary of
what PG can offer you didn't want to push
the boundaries or push the boundary they
wanted to push the boundaries and they did
push them they heard it here so many words
like in that one sequence it's like so many
times that you're like okay I get the joke
but the first time they did it you're like that's
a real bleeped out swear word there totally like
a cunning child could piece together what he just
said what did you think I thought this was lovely
and I've been here like again I do not have the
most comprehensive uh viewing history of the
shrekiverse you know though Shrek is love life
and all of the above I was really dazzled and
delighted by this because you know it's that movie
that came out where I was like okay another Puss
in Boots Shrek movie it'll probably be a whatever
and then you know it's gotten these nominations
and I keep hearing people say how great it is
and sure enough this is like things like this
are gratifying to me where I'm like oh this is fun
enough but also way more than that yeah yeah and
like I thought they had a lot of really beautiful
visual Artistry I thought the story was solid and
not like all right we gotta find something else
for Puss and Boots to do because this is a popular
franchise like it made sense yeah it made sense
I thought it did nice things for the characters
like you said I really liked the gold like the
Goldilocks B plot grew into something that I
just wasn't expecting that was really nice to have
kind of running alongside all this and to further
illustrate the point they could have easily made
her a villain and that whole storyline another
villainous storyline but it's like everybody is
the hero of their own Journey obviously she was
the hero of hers and that was cool I think that
this is it was better than the first person boots
but doesn't hold a candle to Shrek I mean Shrek is
Shrek a Shrek Shrek is Shrek and it was such like
a groundbreaker at the time because I feel like
it was really on the avant-garde of like we're
bringing a more Snappy a more adult accessible
sensibility to a family thing and we're also
being meta and crossing over all these fairy tales
and stuff and so yeah it's like the just the like
sheer fret like Shrek seems to have as much as a
meme now like it feels like it's influenced a lot
in terms of just the scope of at least animated
movies in America since it's come out yeah totally
and also um him and Fiona make out so they do
they do that's what apparently that matters so
what you're saying is the trick is vastly better
just simply due to the makeout quotient it is
yeah that is what I said so okay I I don't know
if it was with Tom but at least again I wasn't
there okay the problem is even if it wasn't in
the actual movie cut someone has animated where
it very much was and you can find that out there
if you said you're already 10 steps ahead of me
I don't know I mean yeah this this I think
excels just by being a good story told well
you know which is sort of Timeless you've been
doing a lot of animated stuff you think this
holds up to or right now in 2023 the animated
genre this is pretty much as good as it gets
I I mean there are certainly things that you could
do that are much more out there and and you know
yeah more off the beaten path with like story
beats and stuff but as as far as like the Assembly
of an animated movie today goes I would say yeah
because this manages to incorporate and blend a
lot of the visual Aesthetics that have been sort
of at the Forefront of Animation lately again like
there's a little bit of spider-verseiness
in the way that they incorporate like the
um I forget what they call this like the action
lines where it's like somebody jumps at the camera
and they've got like little action lines or things
that look like the frame rate has been slowed down
on like a character like the way they really mix
I feel like there's a uniformity that you get used
to when you look at like a Disney Animation or a
Pixar movie where it's all this kind of one thing
happens yes one palette of Animation whereas here
again there were textures that looked very they
were playing and yeah yeah so it gave it this like
additional sense of handcraftedness even though it
is like all in a computer so totally a couple
times you kind of related it to spider verse
which I feel like was uh you doing the most but I
hear what you're saying I mean spider versus like
I am still here thanks for asking post Oh
I thought it was going to be a whole thing
but yeah I mean spider verse for that yeah
like hyper kinetic like we're borrowing from
comic books and we're making it yeah look
a little bit more multimedia than just one
kind of Animation style you're supposed
to look past um so yeah like this will be
now a new Touchstone I can use in the future
when talking about these things because yeah
spider-verse is like cranked up to 15 on that on
that it's not quite 50 you said 15 that's awkward
I like spider-verse better than you do I guess I
guess so or at least you find it more overwhelming
than I do but uh what did you think of it I think
it was it was really solid definitely definitely
preferred this one to the first one just because
there were more layers and more characters I cared
about there was the big twist of the first one
being that Humpty Dumpty is tricking him and isn't
actually his homie and then we twist back and he
untrix them and and works with him so I thought
that that was a very simple uh as opposed to this
with like the death element the goldie element the
jam with his thumb element you know it was just
more kind of going on which I appreciated yeah
and also I really like Soft Paws and I loved she's
in the first one too but I loved watching their
dynamic in this one they kind of seemed like a
match made in heaven and then perito isn't in
the first one so perlito elevates this for sure
oh yeah absolutely I'm big into Patty [Music]
I should have called him out too it's like it
sounds like not you yeah you didn't I did I no
I will I will die on this hill I was like
I can't tell for sure because I only have
what we do in the shadows to go off of but I
was like that sounds so much like Guillermo
I feel as of right now you're lying to me I would
never have got Wagner Mora because I kept sitting
there going I know it's not Javier Bardem but
he's got kind of that like Oaken quality of like
Javier Bardem sometimes when he speaks it sounds
like like a like a ritual tree or something like
that and and uh and I never would have got him
okay but I will die on the perito hill of his of
his voice act perito wouldn't let you die on that
Hill that's true that's true he would have me pet
his belly and he would do the eyes thing he'd use
his one wish to save you I know instead of tearing
the wish apart you could have wished for solving
world hunger if you were gonna just tear it apart
you know you don't have to wish for yourself
you could have wished for her a better life
for everyone yeah anything but instead they were
like nah we all got what we wanted nobody needs
this wish that's true they were all selfish at the
end honestly they're all the worst they suck and
uh this is a bad movie now sorry I just did that
to you it didn't last long it's okay no this is
how I can do it for five seconds this is this is
a good life lesson you know this is what happens
you're welcome reality comes crashing in and you
have to temper uh you know your sentimentality
yeah I'm glad that you know we and the children
who are watching this yeah that was for kids of
the real rejects uh you know we are all learning
this today and growing for the little ones at home
what I'm saying is if you like this movie you are
selfish uh Angry you need to go to therapy little
child yes yeah yeah you should uh go out and do
some community service and really think about what
you did here today think about what you've done
today but yeah hopping back into because the other
thing that was kind of fun is I know this comes
out of Shrek I've met Puss and Boots through Shrek
but it's been a minute since I've seen any of the
Shrek movies and so coming back here I was like
oh cool like the the convergence of fairy tale
characters and worlds still exists here and it's
not necessarily like as in your face or as much
of the point but it's still like it makes this
feel like it's all part of a big world without
feeling obnoxiously like ah Cinematic Universe you
know that was a really fun element of it like even
what's in the bag and the references but with the
cart and the Pumpkin and all the chimney of it all
that was really cool I like that too anything that
makes it feel like you're kind of a kid again and
you're dealing with all the fairy tales yeah the
lines and stuff and with you there yeah because
it works anyway but if you get what the references
are it works that much better you know what's
your favorite character my favorite character
I don't I feel like it's a it's underwhelming
to say it's either like Puss and soft positives
are so great they're both gonna say puss like
soft pause is is so lovely and I just love them
together but puss is like he's great I just
love watching him I love Antonio banderas's
voice I love all the different iterations of his
exploits and whatnot like he is a very I get why
this character has spun off and why people care
if you love put so much then why don't you wear
his boots I will now and I'm gonna go back
and re-watch and watch for the first time in
the first movie and be like you know what this
is my franchise now I think you're gonna like
the first one I don't think you're gonna like it
as much as you like this one I don't anticipate
that either but you know I can imagine at least
going in and be like oh yeah you know it's pretty
fun you're one of my favorite character what
is your favorite what's your guess uh Goldie
because that could be you I did really like
Goldie no but mine's the other lackluster
answer soft pause okay I just love her like
she's great she's hard around the edges but
she also when we see her start to try to teach
perrito and like listen to perito I'm like you
are the perfect balance of tough exterior but
like at the end of the day you were gonna wish
for somebody to trust yeah it's just so relatable
and I know but I do think we should have seen this
I really feel like she didn't actually show up
to the wedding I know that she did show up to
the wedding and she's claiming she didn't yeah
that would have been it would have been cool to
almost like have an interlude or something or yes
see it from at least see from her perspective what
that day looked like to and I went down a whole
journey and we never went down that Journey like
I was like oh and then what happened was and then
she was there and then he wasn't there and then
the the movie was just like no no he just said
what it was stop stop going down that path you've
made things up rocks that feels like something
that they probably wanted to do and maybe had
to trim for time yeah possibly possibly or even
if it wasn't what I'm predicting any version of
just seeing the wedding and whatever it is they
probably cut the whole thing yeah because this
is already what like an hour and 42 minutes and
that's you know that's that's asking some again
like I from talking to animators over time I know
it kind of drives them nuts that animation gets
sort of in America pigeonholed into being the
thing for kids when it's like a whole medium
unto itself yeah um but you know I feel like
being that they definitely want children in
the theater for a movie like this an hour and
once you're over an hour and 40 you're kind of
like okay we're asking a lot of the attention it
did feel a little long the second act dragged a
bit here and that's okay for me and you but I
do think that the first one was 90 minutes and
this one did feel like about 10 minutes longer
you know you can feel yourself being like okay
let's get to that wish What's Happening Here
who's gonna end up at the at the star yeah you
start to be like think about okay let's get
there and then once we get there that third
act goes really really fast yeah yeah and I mean
like I thought they they did nicely to at least
even though yeah like it is it is on the
longer side I think they at least managed to
there was never anything where I was like we'll
just get rid of this yeah like there was a lot
of interesting idea like I loved the idea of the
Dark Forest and that it changes depending on who's
going through and then it kind of looks back into
you as you're pursuing what you think you want out
of it what would your dark force if you're holding
the map what do you think it would have been oh
man oh God uh it would have been like walk down
the the bridge of Bridge of wistfulness and then
uh uh I love the bridge of wistfulness yeah sure
sure so yours would have been celebrated though
no I mean perrito's like got the ideal like
everything's fine in your Zen so you know you're
gonna have an easy time in here as long as you
remember to look around whereas me I feel like
there would be like the valley of anxieties
you know yeah the uh the the swamp of
self-doubt I don't know why I just thought you're
gonna say sweat the swamp a sweat I'm a sweaty
guy it's a swamp of sweat swamp swamp puss in
sweat swamp listen sweats that's who he's gonna
go become now he's gonna be chilling after the
pandemic he's now pushing swallows and sweats
he puts his boots on when he has to go check the
mail or whatever but that's about it listen do I
have to put my boots on today yeah that's part
three and he's dealing with geriatric issues
but that but that too like I like that they're
dealing with mortality and he's aging and it's
like clever and fun because the nine lives thing
but also like you know that's a coming to grips
with the fact that you don't have forever and you
can't just always be this you know you can't be
the character you create for everybody else to
see you know I think it's kind of a nice and a
bit sophisticated of an idea to go for I think
you've automatically I think the default you
associate with animated fair is like believe in
yourself you know that's totally and it'll be that
um which there is some of that but yeah like I
like the way that they had death in here like
actually personified Yes actually confront death
yeah and the way they realize that like there's a
lot of stuff that isn't like you know too much
but is like kind of intense and very visually
striking for a movie like this like when he has
those encounters with death with the red eyes
and then everything gets tinted red and you know
you really feel the impact impact of these blades
and then the sights and everything and like yeah
there's it's really uh I mean part of this is a
horror movie you know that's exactly what I'm
picking up you're putting down it's definitely
a horror movie the Death part really did work for
me too actually though because I do feel like the
whole time sometimes I watch movies selfishly and
you're thinking about yourself during it right
and I kind of was feeling annoyed with puss at
times because I'm like bro I'm so sorry that you
only get nine lives and you're on your last one
and you've already used up eight of them like I
would die to have nine lives you know I would
live so differently it's the whole time I'm
thinking but we only have one life I only have one
life he only gets one life it's so annoying that
you're mad about this and then they addressed that
yeah and I was like oh okay I'm glad that they're
realizing like when perlito talks about it and
then he's like I don't I only have one life but
I'm so happy because I'm with my friends and I
was like that's it perito tell them be here now
perito yeah and then he kind of gets there where
he's just like I only have one life but I'm gonna
fight for it screw you death and I'm like yeah
that's the point the point isn't that you had
nine it's the point is that this is now you get
ones like the rest of us so go work really hard
to live your life yeah don't don't don't spend all
your time looking back on a The Glory Days but be
like oh if I had only had this mindset then you
know like just be here now and make the most out
of it Namaste Namaste all right any stray thoughts
anything do we miss anything straight thoughts
like stray cats gray cat strut are you doing that
on purpose oh no that's my my jazzier Bill and Ted
kind of um sounded more like rocket power yeah
yeah yeah squid we got this it's good well
guys this was super delightful great voice cast
great animation good writing you know everybody
everyone who was involved and even some people
who weren't involved we guessed them too above
and beyond definitely we covered all the base
well guys if you enjoyed this video let us know
leave a comment leave a like check out the World
Girls check out Roxy stryer everywhere social
media books are sold and hey before we leave this
place Let's uh let's make a wish for a lucky patch
Andrew Hayes buddy I wanted to shout you out
today because you know honestly this is an
embarrassment of riches I'm not sure how many
Andrew Hayes could be so many characters from
this movie and right now I'm torn because you
know he's kind of a short guy you know he's
kind of a compact dude but he's also uh you
know he's he's got spunk you know he's got uh
uh imagination he's good picking locks and stuff
he he works for a security company you think he's
puss he's either puss or he's perito because the
other thing is whenever we talk to Andrew he's
just got this good natured way of delivering
things and uh I just always feel better when
I talk to him I don't know I don't know oh so
that's the perrito part he's a combo it's like
I would rub your belly Andrew and and feel at
ease and feel kind of like things are gonna be
okay good Andrea take that with you he'll
rub your belly and he means that truly and
you don't even have to do the cute eyes like if
you want to you can but can you try for Andrew
this is really good it's really
really good I don't know what's happening
with the hands but Andrew appreciates it
that's for you Andrew it's for
you Andrew oh we love you here
at the real Rejects and uh stay pledged
buddy we'll catch you next time in Boots
[Music]
killing it was that a really good cat sound
or no it was a great cat sound that sounded
yeah is that really good yeah it sounds
like copper because like he'll be out
there everyone's got a different meow
and he'll be out there half the time
while we're shooting just oh wait that was
actually a bomb what's wrong you let me
throughout the day it's just burned into my
subconscious a magic subconscious [Music]